[Music]
in the circuit we have three resistors
of different values connected in series
how do we know they're in series because
they connected one after the other
forming just one path and not multiple
paths let's perform a small activity now
close the plucky and note the amateur
reading but these three resistors
connected in series let it be I amperes
next place the ammeter somewhere between
resistors r1 and r2 and note it's
reading similarly place it between r2
and r3 and note the reading what you
will notice is that the current will be
I amperes in each case yes the current
is constant at every point in the
circuit it tells us that in a series
combination of resistors the current
flowing is the same throughout okay
now let's remove the ammeter switch are
between the resistors and try out
something else
now insert a voltmeter across the start
of the first resistor and the end of the
third resistor now plug the key and note
the potential difference across the
resistors let's say it's V volts now
take out the plucky and disconnect the
voltmeter now we insert three volt
meters in the circuit like this one
across each of the resistors now we plug
the key and measure the potential
difference across each of the resistors
you will notice that the potential
difference across each of the resistors
is different let's call them V 1 V 2 and
V 3 respectively even though the
voltages are different you will notice
that the potential difference V will be
equal to the sum of the potential
differences V 1 V 2 and V 3
this helps us derive something very
important look at the entire circuit
first the potential difference is V
volts and the current flowing through it
is I amperes let's say these three
resistors together form a resistance our
arms we still
know what our is but we've just assumed
all three together to provide a
resistance of our arms in the circuit so
according to Ohm's law we can say that
the V is equal to I times R this was the
entire circuit
can you try applying the Ohm's law to
each resistor separately it's easy for
the first resistor the potential
difference is V 1 volts the current
flowing through it is I amperes and the
value of the resistance is R 1 ohms
apply the arms law for the first
resistor we get V 1 equal to I times R 1
similarly for the other two resistors we
applied the arms law to get two more
equations now we can substitute the
values of V V 1 V 2 V 3 in the first
equation to get the result we need V is
I times R V 1 is I times R 1 V 2 is I
times R 2 and V 3 is I times R 3
dividing both sides by I we get the
value of R as this what did we just get
when two or more resistors are connected
in series the overall combined
resistance R is the sum of the
individual resistances now you
understand why the resistance increases
when resistors are connected in series
it's because each resistor when added in
series adds up to the previous
resistance as the resistors are
connected in series we call the overall
resistance RS on a new page let's
quickly review resistors in series take
this simple electric circuit with one
resistor what will happen if I add more
resistors in series the overall
resistance will increase and the current
in the circuit will decrease the current
flowing in the circuit will be the same
at every point in the circuit and the
overall resistance will be the sum of
the individual resistances in the next
lesson we
solve interesting problems related to
resistors connected is series
you